thank you
so encouraging I mean in so many ways to
see just the remarkably stoic nature of
the people of Ukraine and of course
your messaging that I think is reflected
in their courage and in their
determination and in their perseverance
and resilience is just
it's uh you know it's it's to see the
children to see in their eyes
um it's palpable the anxiety and yet the
strength of the Ukrainian people is
something that is
really awe-inspiring in truth so it's uh
and of course you know your messaging is
the reason for that so it's remarkable
to see how you are you know holding this
country and uh and we all we have a good
country well we hold each other yes and
thank you very much for your coming and
and your messages because your coming is
also big message and for us it's very
important are we making a candle oh yeah
yeah you just take one of these it's so
beautiful
you had an incredible experience today
we met a family Natalia and Yuri uh two
parents who have five children of their
own and they receive a house they have a
family house but they took four more
children
four more children incredible people
unbelievable people took four more
children each that their siblings took
them into their home they feed them they
take them to school these children are
not well they have Medicaid medical
needs that's the future for for
hopefully that is the kind of future for
for children who need who are orphaned
in this country because obviously that's
what UNICEF is advocating for as opposed
to Institute institutionalized
institutionalized ways of of raising
children
um we had a very a very uh I heard
everything that was was said today about
um the the missing children and so on
and this is something that I think
UNICEF is taking incredibly seriously
just as the rest of the world is
watching of course president of course
you know he who shall not be mentioned
was made a a war criminal
um because of this and it's and it's so
horrific what's going on but I think
that um if we can create sorry foreign
we can create our two teams jointly to
create the points Steps step by step
what what to do if we can't work because
of course informational wave about the
children how to how to bring them back
and to the everything at this uh
infrastructure for children educational
Network and if we can prepare and then
do big informational web because you
know sometimes when they are like
children when they are waiting you give
straight messages that you will be at
home and then they begin to wait but you
don't have
all facilities and it's also will be big
that's right not good kick for them and
and that's why I think if we can work a
little bit I visited School European
today there were two um two bomb
shelters within the school each could
take about three to five hundred
children and and UNICEF has set them up
great and they they they're they look
like the the the the the child friendly
space it's the light it's and it's the
appropriate safe uh shelter for children
in these circumstances and I think that
is a a very important issue for Unicef
and and I certainly saw one today um
I'm a member of a Buddhist organization
since I'm 16 and my mentor is a Japanese
man in in Japan a man named daisako
acada and in 1994 he wrote a message of
encouragement to the Youth of the UK he
wouldn't see them but he sent this
message this is an excerpt from the
message that he sent to these children
to for them to listen to he reserved
himself from being there but I wanted to
read it because I feel it's so important
and I had it written for you as well to
read along but it says the times are
changing from an age where Justice from
an age where power is justice
to an age in which Justice is power
in this new age the Supreme guiding
principle will be the benefit of all
Humanity rather than the interests of
one particular Nation or ethnic group we
will see the transformation of history
from the revolution of the external
environment to that of the inner self
the inner Human Revolution it will be an
age in which the actions of leaders will
naturally be based on the guidelines of
making all mothers happy
a great future lies ahead of you you
must fix your eyes on that future never
losing sight of your goal even for one
single moment centuries tens of
centuries have waited for you to arrive
and have been preparing for you you are
the ones who have appeared now so
mystically your Victory would be the
victory of humanism your defeat will be
the defeat of Hope
hence you must win in everything you
must fight with an indomitable spirit
one's Fortune was against a knight who
was captured in battle by his enemies
and had his castle confiscated
where is your Castle now they asked
laughing scornfully you have lost
everything they implied the night
answered resolutely holding his head
high my castle is in my heart
cool you have a heart pain to someone
you have a strong heart and thank you
for everything you do